die berliner staatsanwaltschaft will den
skandal rapper fler für mehr als zwei
jahre hinter gitter stecken nach bild
informationen ist der musiker vor einem
erweiterten schöffengericht in mehr als
20 fällen angeklagt insgesamt umfasst
die anklage 17 prall gefüllte akten
recherchiert hat den fall für uns
matthias becker matthias leja 20 fälle
die dort vor gericht verhandelt werden
um was handelt es sich denn da konkret
also seine liste der vorbestraften taten
ist schon lang dies länger als eine
liste seiner nummer eins alben
jetzt kommt noch mal ein gesamtpaket
hinzu er hat ein sonderstaatsanwalt
bekommen der ist in der abteilung der ak
wie mir gesagt wurde
der hat zusammengefasst ungefähr sechs
fahren ohne fahrerlaubnis führerschein
er hat bedroht beleidigt er soll während
eines videodrehs graffiti schmierereien
in berlin charlottenburg am
theodor-heuss-platz begangen haben
dazu gab es auch noch einen tipp geber
bei der deutschen bahn die mir gesagt
wurde wir auch noch eine anklage dazu zu
erwarten hat pikant besonders ist dabei
dieses viral durch die decke gegangen
eine video dieses sogenannte fanboy du
bist ein fanboy und das hat er während
einer polizeikontrolle immer wieder
einen polizisten gegenüber weisheit dazu
hat seine lebensgefährtin freundinnen
wie auch immer dazu das handy gezückt
und die ganzen situation minuten lang
aufgenommen
auch auf drängen der beamten das nichts
zu tun das ist die vertraulichkeit des
gesprochenen wortes hat sie es nicht
unterlassen sie hat weiter gedreht auf
dem video hat flair auch noch gesagt und
morgen das sagt ihr zu dem polizisten
wirst du dich auf video und youtube
wiederfinden das ist die arbeitsteilige
vorgehensweise deswegen ist nicht nur in
dem punkt flair an geplant sondern eben
auch seine lebensgefährtin und die
beiden stehen nur vor diesem
schöffengericht erklären dass ein
bisschen
genauer was ist dieses schöffengericht
und warum kommt das zum einsatz in
diesem fall ja auch ganz interessant
der staatsanwalt hat es ganz klug gesagt
also das sind so viele anzeigen und so
viele vorwürfe die ja hat das ist mit
den ganzen zeugen das sind dutzende von
zeugen das kann ein einfaches gericht
ein amtsgericht und auch ein einfaches
schöffengericht nicht leisten dass
arbeitet ein erweitertes schöffengericht
mit dem zu erwartenden strafe von
deutlich über zwei jahren so hat die
staatsanwaltschaft ausgelobt dass es
deren ziel jetzt endlich einer zu bieten
und man muss auch eins wissen man wollte
erst mal einen kaffee jetzt mit den über
20 strafverfahren setzen nicht dazu ist
der übergriff auf ein aktuell kamerateam
nicht die bedrohung nicht die
sachbeschädigung das kommt später
nochmal on top mann wollte jetzt hier
wirklich erstmal ein schlussstrich
ziehen